so i always chuckle about things like
for example you know i look i ran for
president i finished in third place in
the delegate count i made it all the way
to florida it didn't turn out the way i
wanted it to but that was god's plan for
for our country and for my life and i
you know things uh there are a lot of
things i've been able to do over the
last four years i wouldn't have been
able to do if i had won that race or
never been the nominee
and uh and you know they called me up
for a long time they wrote about marco
rubio failed presidential candidate
you know kamala harris didn't even make
it out of california she didn't even
make it to
december hold it zero
yeah cory booker didn't even make it to
descend they'd even make it to the first
state and they're called former
presidential candidates so i'm a failed
one they're a former one i don't care
but it's an example of that sort of
double standard and and it exists and i
think there comes a point where you kind
of realize who cares
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
with my first interview from the free
state of florida we got the right guy
for it florida senator marco rubio
senator how are you
i'm good glad to have you here and just
a disclaimer at the outset this is like
real world right here i'm in my backyard
i got my dog is right here so if you
hear a little barking that's why i'm
using these but uh
we're not trying to stage anything here
it's all real man so i apologize ahead
if he barks you're going full florida
man so first off as you as you know i
just moved here from the crazy state of
california i've been here for a couple
weeks just moved into the house i'm in
my makeshift studio now you were nice
enough to uh to do a little promo video
for me welcoming me here so let's just
start with the state of florida first i
mean what is it about florida that
sort of allowed florida to do it right
over these last two years like i don't
think it's just the political part
although that's a part of it what is it
about just sort of the florida man the
florida woman that that did something
right here
that's a great question i do think it
starts with political leadership but
maybe the the truth is that the the
people produce that political leadership
they reward a certain kind of leadership
and don't reward others but you know i
think the key thing about florida
understand is that everyone's from
somewhere else for the most part and
that means another part of the country
like you and me are hundreds of
thousands of people in florida that have
done what you've done and that is you
came here because you didn't like what
life was like under the leadership of
people in some other state and so when
people come to a place to get away from
that kind of stuff they came for a
reason so i think that's a big part of
it and it's not just from other states
we also have people that come from other
countries so here in south florida as
i'm sure you've already experienced we
have a lot of people that obviously came
from cuba or their parents did and then
venezuela and then nicaragua and so any
time that there is or for that matter
you know any time there's any sort of a
left-wing disruption in latin america so
for example peru
elected a president who's far left and
even anti-american and suddenly you see
the real estate purchases from peruvian
skyrocket
people come here to get away from that
stuff they come here from other
countries they come here from other
states and i think that's a big big part
of
of what makes florida what it is and
it's something we really need to protect
you know and it's a dynamic state in
many ways it's sort of a 21st century
frontier state in that way well listen
man i am here to protect it as i keep
telling people i'm here to keep i'm here
to keep florida florida i have noticed
you know you mentioned the international
part of this i mean one thing i've
definitely noticed in a couple weeks
here especially in the miami area i mean
everyone brings their own driving
customs here there is a certain set of
ways that you drive in florida that i
have not seen in california before
yeah i mean it's all it's always the
game about you know can i beat the red
light or is it a you know it's all like
a 10-second rule on the red light you
know like the light is red but does it
really mean red or do i get something
like you drop something on the floor you
get a you know it's a two second rule
whatever same thing with that um you
know everybody's trying to figure out
how to use a back street to cut through
traffic um there's a little bit of that
you know and it's part of the flare of
the place i'm not encouraging people to
do it but it's part of the sort of the
character of it i think that's true
probably more in south florida than in
other parts of the state but um
but it is uh yeah no it's different no
i'm not um i've definitely become a bit
of a venezuelan or cuban driver already
in a couple weeks here but in these last
two years that that florida continued to
flourish while so many states collapsed
and as you said there are quite
literally hundreds of thousands of
people moving in this direction right
now
what do you do
to stop people who made the mistakes in
the blue states from repeating those
mistakes here i'm not going to repeat
those mistakes but you know obviously
some people will
yeah i think first of all it's
self-selective i mean you know i'm not
saying that's true for everybody but the
frankly the bottom line is this if you
live in california and you watch msnbc
habitually you spend all day on twitter
you think that in florida we have bodies
all over the streets and we have you
know people are just dying left and
right and governor desantis is the
leader of a death cult so you're not
going to move to florida if that's what
you think unless some your job makes you
or something so by and large people that
are moving here are people that are they
don't believe that stuff uh when they
come now that doesn't mean that's true
for everybody and look this is a
state with diverse opinions but look
this has always been a state that's had
liberals this has always been a state
that's have people that are left of
center
on their political views but i don't
think that's the dividing line anymore i
mean i think you can be a liberal and
not be crazy i think what we're talking
about now is things that go well beyond
just traditional i want higher taxes and
more government this is the complete
total abandonment of common sense of
balance of a reason and and almost so
hysteria on on its approach to different
issues and and um
and i do think we've avoided a lot of
that happening here that doesn't mean
it's not present at all but i i don't
see a lot of that happening i mean you
know that there aren't people that hold
those views or to talk in those ways but
but but i think what's really important
is to show the results right at the end
of the day there's a reason why
ocasio-cortez and and you know all these
other members of congress come down here
to vacation and party on new year's eve
and it and it's because you know they
may be in favor of the rules or at least
publicly in favor of the rules in their
home state but when it comes time to
actually enjoy life they're coming here
they're not going to some of these other
places and um
and so i think reminding people that and
and comparing you know us to these other
states and what they're going through uh
is one of the most important things we
can continue to do to convince people
and win this battle do you ever envy
the fact that the democrats can get away
with virtually anything like aoc can be
partying down here at clubs you know
mask lists and the whole thing while
she's locking down her own people when
clearly if you were to do anything that
the media could figure out in some
slight way was hypocritical or when say
senator cruz went on a vacation that was
long planned for a couple days they go
bananas but democrats can pretty much do
anything do you ever get a little
jealous of that
you know that's a great question and let
me tell you what happens and i can talk
to you about my evolution on all of this
i think when you first kind of get into
politics you know i got elected ten
years ago and i get there and i'm new to
the place and all that and so
whether it's the people around you or
just your own instincts you sort of
think all right you guys yes they're
left of center and they're liberal but
at some point there's some fairness in
them right and
and so i think you waste a lot of time
thinking you're going to impress people
you know from in the in the legacy media
and i think that's worse than it's ever
been when i when
in terms of their bias and so forth
and and i think maybe one of the things
that donald trump revealed is you're
never going to impress these people i
mean they're never going to treat you
the same as as they do the other side i
think once you abandon that and once you
accept it that's a fact
and then the next step is realizing by
the way a lot of people know this like
there's a lot of people out there that
notice this double standard and so i
always chuckle about things like for
example you know i look i ran for
president i finished in third place in
the delegate count i made it all the way
to florida it didn't turn out the way i
wanted it to but that was god's plan for
for our country and for my life and i
you know things uh there are a lot of
things i've been able to do over the
last four years i wouldn't have been
able to do if i had won that race or
never been the nominee
and uh and you know they called me up
for a long time they wrote about marco
rubio failed presidential candidate
you know kamala harris didn't even make
it out of california she didn't even
make it to december
zero
yeah cory booker didn't even make it to
december didn't even make it to the
first state and they're called former
presidential candidates so i'm a failed
one they're a former one i don't care
but it's an example of that sort of
double standard and and it exists and i
think there comes a point where you kind
of realize who cares like it doesn't
really matter people
say people see it and frankly people
don't believe it anymore we're just not
living in an era now there are more
people that will watch this podcast then
we'll read you know what the local
newspaper writes about me on any given
day and and once you sort of realize
that
it makes life a lot easier you know if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell